The (Carcharodon) Megalodon is thought to
have looked very much like a Great White Shark,
only a bit more stocky and overall bigger.
If they idea of a bigger version of a Great
White Shark isn’t frightening enough to
you, perhaps we should say how much bigger.
The average adult Megalodon is estimated to
have weighed around 70-100 tons (about 30
times that of a Great White Shark which full
grown tend to be about 2.5-3 tons).
The Megalodon is also estimated to have been
around 15-24 meters long (50-78 ft., compared
to a typical adult Great White Shark which
is only 6m or 20 ft long).
It is also estimated that the bite force the
Megalodon’s jaws could generate was somewhere
in the vicinity of 11-18 tons of force.
For reference, this is about 6-10 times the
biting power of a Great White Shark and 18-30
times that of a Lion.
Not only were its jaws exceptionally powerful,
but the Megalodon had teeth as large as 18
cm long (7 inches- in fact, “Megalodon”
literally means “giant tooth”), which
are today the most common remnants of the
Megalodon found.
These teeth didn’t just have powerful jaws
helping them to slice through prey, but they
also are serrated and deeply planted in the
jaw, so as not to break loose or chip when
biting even through thick bones of another
creature.
This giant of the sea seems to have traveled
far and wide, with their teeth found throughout
the globe.
Based on fossil evidence (particularly chewed
remains of certain things), its favorite food
is thought to have been marine mammals, but
it also would eat other things.
Among the known things it preferred to eat
were dolphins, squids, whales (including very
large ones like Sperm Whales), sea lions,
porpoises, giant sea turtles, and the like.
So if this was such a big and powerful creature,
seemingly the king of the ocean, what happened
to the Megalodon?
There are a variety of theories, but mainly
it’s thought its extinction came about due
primarily to climate change.
The Megalodon preferred warmer waters and
thanks to global cooling of the Earth’s
oceans starting around 15-17 million years
ago and culminating into the last Ice Age,
the Megalodon died out around the end of the
Pliocene era (about 2.5 million years ago).
At this point, the Earth’s global temperature
had cooled to just about 2-3° C (3.6-5.4°
F) higher than today.
It’s thought this may have simultaneously
resulted in a lessening of available warm
water breeding sites and a decline in available
food supply due to many of the whales it fed
on either dying out or moving towards more
polar regions where the water was now too
cold for the Megalodon.
Without an abundance of reasonable sized prey
to feed on, the extremely large and voracious
Megalodon couldn’t last long.
It’s thought that as food became scarce,
the Megalodons even began resorting to cannibalism,
and young Megalodons were particularly susceptible,
further accelerating their progress towards
extinction, which ultimately happened around
1.6-2 million years ago.
Bonus Fact:
• Contrary to what certain films show, the
Megalodon was not alive when dinosaurs roamed
the Earth.
The dinosaurs went extinct around 65 million
years ago, while the Megalodon didn’t pop
up until about 25 million years ago and wasn’t
prevalent until approximately 17 million years
ago.